what's up guys this is 10 things you
didn't know about Dark Souls or maybe
you do know them let's play a bit of a
game with it if I tell you something new
in this video leave a like if you
recognize everything in this video then
feel free to leave a dislike let's get
started number one you can actually get
to the end of gwendolyn's chamber
there's no trick to it just keep running
for about 5 or 10 minutes
number 2 the eyes of a basilisk aren't
exactly what they'd sing assumedly
they're a method of intimidation here
are its real eyes number 3 also the
teeth of a minik are actually human
fingers number 4 the polls within the
clams are actually skulls it explains
why they drop purging stones since
purging stones don't strictly cure
cursors they're essentially other humans
that draw the curse out of you and into
them instead number 5 is something that
you'll notice all throughout an Orlando
there are two sizes of the area one is
devoted to humans the other is the right
size for Giants take this staircase for
example number 6 there's a few places in
Dark Souls that are remarkably similar
to places in the real world see if you
can name one area where the inspiration
is obvious for example the interior here
looks like the same as a castle in
France called chateau de chambord and
you can almost definitely say that the
arches here were based off Milan
Cathedral in Italy number 7 is that the
first time you enter ash lake the music
only starts when you look at the sky
number eight is that an extremely rare
mob called a vagrant exists which are
monsters that spawn in response to large
quantities of Souls humanities or items
being lost in another player's world now
you might already know this but did you
know that there's four different types
there's an evil vagrant which is white
with a claw an evil vagrant which is red
with a claw a good vagrant which is
white and an egg shape and a good
vagrant which is red with an egg shape
number nine there's a unique stab
animation when you attack another player
lying in the coffin in the catacombs and
lastly number 10
you can aim crossbow bolts semi reliably
by looking through the binoculars and
moving your camera all right so if
you're still around first off thank you
I don't know why since that video wasn't
exactly the best thing in the world but
hey it allowed me to keep my promise of
one video a week so that's pretty good
at any rate I just want to use this time
to give a bit of an update about the
channel since some things have happened
in the past few days and they all sort
of revolve around a little thing called
a copyright claim and that's pretty
scary word if you do any uploading on
YouTube even if you make a video with
copyrighted content that falls under
fair use most of the time it's in
YouTube's best interest to side with the
publisher of that video and deal you a
copyright strike against your account
which gets rid of most of your features
on this note if you've checked my
channel recently for some reason you'll
notice that I had to remove my Dark
Souls 2 interview and gameplay analysis
I used clips and audio from the IGN
interview that triggered a match with
their content on YouTube but luckily
this content isn't a copyright strike
against my account if I disputed the
matter in the name of fair use though it
could easily have become one so I took
the safest option and I deleted those
videos for now I'm currently working on
redoing those videos but this time I'll
be using still screenshots without the
irritating IGN watermark so redoing
those videos will be what my next week
consists of thanks IGN at any rate this
should make it pretty clear that if
you're alone on YouTube it can make you
pretty vulnerable and this is why I'm
happy to announce that I managed to get
a partnership with the game station this
past week who should be able to provide
me a bit more channel security and what
does this mean to you very little the
style or regularity of my uploads one
change but I definitely feel more safe
under a network so I can keep doing what
I'm doing and to keep you guys happy and
clearly some of you are happy since I've
gotten to the point where I am now why
are there so many of you because of you
all sharing and liking my stuff so thank
you honestly every time you do those
things it helps and I don't want to
waste the opportunity you guys have
given me on this platform so after all
this copyright drama hopefully I can
actually start making videos again
instead of deleting them I look forward
to it and I'll see you guys next time
you